okay
we are already getting ready for all the sour farmers reactions
there we go hr
is not your friend
that's what this video is about
incoming all sour hr
uh duets is okay
I put on my special rights sweater for it
will be fine hr is not your friend
there we go hr is not your friend
HR is often a huge department at large companies
and half of what happens in an HR department
as an employee you often do not even get along
from hr is to start
a large part recruitment and training
of existing employees
so that has nothing to do with you
and your terms of employment
and certainly not with any conflicts
that you have in the workplace
hr is paid by your employer
to solve problems of the company
not yours
there may be problems
in the broadest sense of the word
it can be about problems
with your and any terms of employment
it can be about problems between you
and another employee
but it can also go
about a problem between you and for example
the rules of the company
so don't expect that either
for example if you have a conflict with your manager
or another supervisor in the workplace
that hr immediately chooses your side
hr is not your friend
hr is a third party
that involves conflict in a conflict
hopefully for that
to solve
but that solution does not have to be in your favor
to be
that solution only has to be one thing for hr
and that is the advantage for the company
and as your advantage
in that case is the advantage of the company
is that nice for you
but it is not what she is going for
HR department is incredibly complex and very large
and this is definitely not a video to sit on hr
employees but as an employee you have to understand that hr
defends a lot of different interests
that are not necessarily yours
and if you have a problem
that it can help to other parties
to involve as many as 100
keep an eye on your interests
such as a union
a lawyer or other party who is 100
fight for you